wednesday edition of pft ot that's the
program that we do after pft live goes
off the air things that we either didn't
get to or things we would like to talk
some more about and it was a three-man
weave edition of pft live today so now
it's down to just two two we got rid of
big cat he was leaving anyway it's down
to me and chris sims and we're gonna
delve into some of the things we talked
about earlier including the issue that
chris we've been ahead of the curve on
this i'm not trying to pat ourselves on
the back but let me pat ourselves on the
back yes we've been making people aware
that there's something up with the
seahawks and russell wilson and wilson
now says he wants his contract by april
15. he's made it clear via his visit to
jimmy fallon he wants to be the highest
paid player in football so if you're the
seahawks what do you do about this yeah
i i mean to me this would be something
again you know i don't expect anything
to be done by april 15. do you i mean i
don't think that's even realistic at
this point it doesn't sound like i feel
like we would have heard rumors that
things were you know farther down the
road as far as contract talks and things
like that so have no idea where they're
at but if i'm the if i'm the seattle
seahawks i'm i'm trying to get this done
this off season i am uh russell wilson
without question the most famous most
notable you know notable player in the
history of the seattle seahawks russell
wilson without question is one of the
five best quarterbacks in football and i
just think if i'm the seattle seahawks i
don't let a talent like that out the
door and i would try to find a way right
now hey fine if you got to make him the
highest paid quarterback in football
right now that's that's all fine and
dandy i think in with the way the salary
caps going right mike and everything
there you know okay you're the richest
quarterback this year three years from
now
it will be you know the 10th highest
paid quarterback in football and i think
that will help out the seattle seahawks
and the long-term long-term prospects of
their football team to kind of get get
out ahead of this
i really think what's going on is this
and i'm going to explore whether or not
this theory has any merit once we finish
up today but i think that the seahawks
have been trying to get him to sign a
long-term deal he's been resisting it
and eventually he said all right here's
what it's going to be
i want to be the highest paid player in
football and it's got to be done by
april 15. otherwise no long-term deal i
think he wants to do the kirk cousins
one year at a time because he knows at
some point he forces his way to the open
market and the seahawks want to sign him
on the open market so be it they can but
this is a way to bring some of that nba
attitude into the nfl we've seen it with
kirk cousins we've seen it with antonio
brown and we may be seeing it with
russell wilson and i know it's out of
character but just the fact that there
would be a story that he's given them
this deadline this artificial deadline
of april 15 for a long-term contract
that's out of character yeah so
hey he's 30 now he's got other issues
he's considering he's made a certain
amount of money he sees how much more he
can make and he knows there's a finite
number of years that he can make it
right now is the time to shake as much
as you can out of the trees and i think
one way or the other he's going to make
34 million over the next four years and
it's either going to be as part of a
long-term contract chris or it's going
to be franchise tag 2020 franchise tag
2021 and if the seahawks are willing to
do it 52.4 million for the franchise tag
in 2022. yeah i don't know i mean is it
that out of character i was just gonna
say two because he is a guy that seems
pretty straightforward business oriented
understands the full scope of the league
he always kind of threatens about this
i'm going to go play baseball for a week
with the new york yankees he never says
he's going to play baseball full-time
you're right you're right he never says
this is the this is the first time he
has deviated in any way from the
carefully manicured
go hawks image and that was the way that
they would do it in the locker room
behind his back when you know the rough
and tumble guys were there and resented
the fact that he was kind of management
among them and now that they've built
the team around him it's even more
imperative that they keep him that he's
got a ton of leverage here i mean a ton
a ton and they're either gonna pay
they're either gonna pay him aaron
rodgers plus or they're gonna be paying
him over the next four years the same
amount and then they may not have him
after the next three or four years go by
all right aaron rodgers plays for the
packers was coached by mike mccarthy
mike mccarthy not happy with the way
things ended in green bay and i'm a i'm
a big believer in this chris if you
believe you were not treated fairly let
others make that case for you don't make
it for yourself it's hard to generate
sympathy if it looks like you're whining
and the way that i read this article as
it relates to how he was fired his
complaints about the how it couldn't
have been handled any worse yes it could
have been handled wars it could have
been handled much worse and i know
stories of exit interviews gone horribly
wrong between employer and employee he's
unhappy that there wasn't enough emotion
involved in it what are they supposed to
do breakdown crying it's over it's done
you're still getting paid for the rest
of this year and at least all of next
year i don't understand why he's
choosing to try to make himself seem
sympathetic that's not for him to do
and it's just odd that he's that he's
still holding that grudge three and a
half months after the fact yeah no it it
is odd i i knew for a guy who won this
you know has won a super bowl and played
in a lot of big games first of all i do
agree with you like you know you
shouldn't be the one to come out and
complain in these type of instances i
don't think it's good for the mike
mccars mccarthy business you know again
the future employers they're gonna
these are things that i don't think are
necessarily gonna rub them the right way
uh you know even even the con you know
the comments about aaron rodgers you
better be careful because other
quarterbacks players if he's uh a little
too you know mean in those comments or
in you know indicting somebody for their
actions that's not going to make anybody
feel comfortable if he becomes a new
head coach of their football team either
but let's not forget like the optics of
this situation i mean
they lost at home to the arizona
cardinals the team that has the number
one pick in the draft okay the worst
team in football went up to green bay in
december with a rookie quarterback and
beat mike mccarthy and aaron rodgers in
green bay
and yes mike mccarthy might not like how
it went down and didn't show emotion but
i think that was just the final nail in
the coffin i think that the green bay
packers brass already was probably going
i think we're going to move on from
aaron from from mike mccarthy here and
when you lose in that fashion at home to
one of the worst teams in football
that'll speed up the process and yes you
know uh mike mccarthy's a good football
coach you know my issues with him on the
offensive side of the ball and hey this
is business it's part of football and
for some reason coaches especially
coaches that are established i know i
said this on tv mike they feel like they
get the right to end a season or get to
finish what they started and i think
that's a little hypocritical because
there's of course a lot of players in
the nfl who don't get that right on a
yearly basis
yeah and and i agree with that
completely they fire players all the
time and most players don't have
guaranteed contracts beyond the moment
they're fired coaches do that's what
he's going to be paid for all of 2019
and then he'll try to get back into the
the coaching hiring process when 2020
rolls around and i just i just look
i think that he
he got a lot more leeway than any other
coach ever would have gotten he didn't
get the most out of aaron rodgers over
the course of his time there yes they
won a super bowl but that that absence
of an owner who can fire you whenever he
or she chooses to do so does create a
complacent environment or an environment
that is more more apt to be complacent
so it's more important to fight to avoid
complacency when you know that there
isn't that billionaire lurking the halls
who can hand out pink slips whenever he
or she chooses right to do so yeah all
right
there was a billionaire who was lurking
the halls of the alliance of american
football and we thought tom dundon was
committed to multiple years of putting
the money in necessary to try to make
the thing profitable and he has decided
after only about six weeks chris he's
done the aaf is done the af is gone the
xfl arrives next year we have seen
alternate football we have seen spring
football leagues fail over the years can
it ever work and is the xfl in your
opinion something that would work much
better than the aaf i don't think it can
work i don't think the xfl it might have
better success than the aaf but i don't
think it's gonna necessarily work it
might hang around for you know two three
years maybe at its best but no you know
for me a guy that loves football uh
first of all the nfl is all there is to
me when it comes to football it's the
best athletes in our country maybe the
best athletes in the world all competing
against each other you get the best
coaches also involved in that
conversation so you're taking a notch
down as far as uh
the talent level the coaching experience
the ideas all those things that go with
it so that that gets me there and hey
honestly hey
spring football in college in the south
that's still king
and the biggest thing with any of these
startup leagues and i've said this a lot
is there's just no star power like the
usfl back in the 80s had a chance
because they paid some of the guys who
were going to be top 10 draft picks
enough money to sway them to leave the
nfl and come play in the usfl and that's
why i created some buzz i know
ultimately it went bankrupt but didn't
work but that to me is where the big
issue is mike we watch college football
because we see greatness on the field at
times we see saquon barkley playing on
penn state versus you know a bunch of
college kids and we go wow that was
amazing look at these amazing things we
see kyler murray who we think is going
to be a star in the nfl dominate certain
games in college football and that's why
we tune in we tune in to see the
greatness of those players and some of
those coaches and that goes for the nfl
and that's where i look at the xfl or
the aaf and just think they have major
issues there
you need star players you need players
with name recognition and the idea of of
getting players on loan from the nfl
makes sense as long as it's players we
care about and that's the problem if you
want to help your backup quarterback
develop and you put him on loan to the
xfl
okay fine he may develop but he also may
get injured then you're screwed and you
don't have a backup quarterback so it's
a very fine line for the nfl and the
question is can you attract talent that
will forego playing in the nfl that's
what i think the xfl is going to do
they're going to target guys who get cut
on labor day weekend and they they would
otherwise be the third string
quarterback or the fourth string
quarterback get those guys to commit to
the xfl they're not available for that
roster churning that we see when guys
get signed and released and guys get
injured and and and that's a way for the
xfl to get some decent players with nfl
reps but that still doesn't mean we're
like are we going to care about luke
falk and david fails in the xfo no i
don't know what it's going to take to
resonate they almost really do have to
revolutionize the game they do and and
you know whether that and one thing
about the af like
these games that were 13 to 9 who cares
right they need to have games that land
in the 30 to 40 point range per team
every game and it needs to feel like
it's moving fast it needs to be exciting
your offenses need to click and the
offenses have a hard time catching up
with defenses and if the defenses are
ahead of the curve these games are not
going to be exciting chris no no exactly
right i think you made a lot of spoil a
lot of good points and i think that's it
i mean what can you know the wwf or the
xfl
bring to the table that's going to
attract the fans on a weekly basis and
you said it i think they're going to
have to find some style of play or some
you know i i don't want to say gimmick
but that's the word i'll use for lack of
a better phrase that's going to get
people to interested to watch the game
to go oh that's different like this is
kind of neat how they're playing i don't
know what that is but they're gonna have
to find a different angle it can't be
like the aaf where yeah it's bland
offensive play bland defensive play and
there's no uh exciting football players
on the field and like you said every
game looked the same it was always 13 9
16 10
17 7. it just uh there was no there's
just nothing that allured me to it on a
weekly basis
all right i'm gonna skip a topic that we
were planning to discuss we talked about
it during the show this was the jim
irsay three super bowls in a row i don't
know what more to say about that other
than jim what the hell are you doing
let's just win
first let's just stay there yeah let's
just go one try to get one
let's not have a goal that no one has
ever achieved ever before in the history
of the sport at least in the super bowl
era but i'm skipping it for an important
reason i have an
update on russell wilson that we'll get
to after we get to our next topic oh
here is what i want i want to it's a
little time i'm holding the audience in
place to the extent that they're they're
even watching this and i think some of
them do here's one that i want to get to
before we get to russell wilson and this
relates to derek carr we talked during
the show about the raiders tweet of kyle
murray with tim brown on their official
account on the day they did the private
workout with kyle murray the derek carr
response with the robert de niro i'm
watching you focker uh gesture and derek
carr clearly not happy with what's going
on
what what if if derek carr
called you today yeah and said chris
i know you dealt with john gruden for
multiple years in tampa bay you know
what makes the guy tick you've had other
quarterbacks drafted signed acquired
tell me what i should do about this
situation what advice would you give
derek my advice would be hey listen john
gruden's he's passionate about a
football you're going to learn a lot of
good things derek carr but the the big
thing is here you can't also let john
gruden bother you derek carr you got to
block out some of the noise and when
he's talking about quarterbacks and how
other quarterbacks are so great
excuse me
and his eye fancies some of the young
quarterbacks coming out in the draft and
uh obviously he has a fascination with
kyla murray he's been talking pretty
highly about him ever since the combine
really and of course he works them out
so my advice to derek carr would be
don't let those things bother you and
don't let john gruden or the oakland
raiders show that they bother you you
know one of the things we need derek
carr everybody questions is the
thickness of his skin can he handle a
john gruden well this is a litmus test
in that area and also what happens and i
almost fell down this little tunnel
myself when i played for john gruden
when you start to let him bother you it
starts to take away from what you do on
the field and that's the big thing when
you start thinking oh this bastard he's
gonna bring another quarterback he's not
giving me enough reps you know what a
jerk can't believe he talked to me like
that in the meeting i found myself those
were days where i didn't have a good day
at practice or i wasn't at my best
because i wasn't focused on the job at
hand and all he can do is worry about
himself his play where he is at
physically and that's where he should go
and just do your best to block the noise
the hell derek carr is showing that he
pays attention to the media a little too
much with stuff like this with he wanted
to box somebody right uh an espn because
they were saying wrong things or
whatever it may be he's showing that the
criticism or the questions get to him
and i don't think that's necessarily a
good look for him so for me i would just
block it out and kind of get off the
radar derek carr
and
is there any merit to the idea that if
you're going to survive the fray of a
professional football game
that
you got to be able to deal with this
group yes i mean is it is it is it
helpful does it thicken your skin or is
it a distraction which way do you fall
on that yeah no i i think it's helpful i
think it's another test where you can
put a you know the pelt on the horse as
you and i say and you can go i don't say
that another another obstacle another
obstacle that i've overcome and i
continued to stay focused and had the
tunnel vision to not be distracted by
the outside noise that's what being a
quarterback is in the nfl hey of course
you want to self-motivate he's not going
to forget that gruden flirted with with
other quarterbacks but his goal should
really be i'm going to play so good that
this john gruden's got to keep me i'm
going to be a starting quarterback and
i'm gonna play so good that i'm gonna
take jabs at him for looking at other
dumb quarterbacks that i didn't think
were worthy of what i am and that's what
you almost have to be motivated in that
to go i'm gonna show this guy and i'm
gonna let him know this bothered me once
i do show him down the road and go well
you know you almost ruined this whole
thing what an idiot you were you almost
drafted somebody else and look at look
at what i've done and our team has done
that's what you got to be uh the end
goal end game kind of looking forward to
all right it's time to wrap this up i'm
interested that we have to pay off the
tease here's what here's what i know and
this is the ultimate multitasking this
is text message exchanges with sources
regarding russell wilson so you weren't
listening to me is what you were saying
i wasn't listening to you yeah but
someone contacted me with some
information so i had to go back and
forth and play the game a little bit but
here's what i can now report and this
isn't on pft yet but it will be soon
enough
russell wilson is not going to hold out
he will be there right every day that
the doors to the facility are open
they were told in late january that the
deadline is april 15 so this isn't
something new right and it is a very
simple proposition get a contract done
or he is going to go year to year under
the franchise tag now there are factors
that need to be considered when we get
into a long-term contract and it isn't
going to simply be
pay me what i would make under the
franchise tag over the next four years
the issue of quarterback contract
escalation and we've talked in the past
that you can't have a term in there that
guarantees you a percentage of the
salary cap as the cap goes up and up and
up no team has done that yet but players
have tried to get it how the cap will
increase what will happen under a new
cba how the money will go up with
legalized gambling how the money will go
up with new national tv deals these are
all things that are projections at this
point but i think russell wilson is
going to want to have that accounted for
in some way in this contract it requires
a level of creativity that aaron rodgers
wanted in green bay and the packers
wouldn't give it to him and he
eventually shrugged his shoulders and
signed a normal deal the question is
will the seahawks do an unconventional
deal or will they let russell wilson
follow what is a largely unconventional
approach of one year at a time under the
franchise tag and i think if if wilson
is trying to take all these factors and
turn them into something quantifiable
it's going to be less likely that the
seahawks are going to bite yeah no i you
know again russell wilson did the
seattle seahawks a solid the last time
he negotiated his contract he was he
signed a team-friendly deal he did not
hold their feet over the fire to be the
highest paid guy or top two or three in
all the football which he certainly had
the right to do at the time uh i i would
say this if i'm the seahawks and i know
i already said this i would sign him to
a long-term deal and get out in front of
it right now because the year to year
thing is i think a franchise killer it's
a locker room killer at the quarterback
position other positions you can get
away with it but we just saw an
experiment with the washington redskins
with kirk cousins who did the same thing
and there was a disconnect there's a
disconnect between the players and the
quarterback in the locker room the
coaches and the quarterback have a
disconnect there and you question how
all in or emotionally invested the
quarterback is in the organization over
the long haul in the future when it's a
year to year thing and the quarterback
you're going ah i might not be here next
year i don't know where this is going to
go so to me that's where it can really
play
an issue with a football team and i
don't see pete carroll or john schneider
who i have a ton of respect for wanting
to do that to their locker room or have
to answer those questions all off season
for three consecutive off season so if
i'm then get this done make him the
highest paid quarterback in all of
football make it a long-term deal so the
yearly the yearly cap hit is uh not a
crushing number and i think that would
be the best way to approach it at least
in my opinion
yeah and we'll see if they can work
something out but the deadline is clear
it's the start of the off-season program
and i i think russell wilson if nothing
else is a man of his word and if he says
that's the deadline that's the deadline
and it's not going to be on april 16 oh
russell you know we changed our mind
we'll agree to it now that that will be
intriguing if they do all of a sudden
cave the day after will he stick to his
guns or will he say okay if you're going
to give me what i wanted anyway so be it
but but i think that he really is
standing on principle here he's given
him a fair opportunity to get to where
he wants to be and now we'll see whether
or not they get there all right we've
gotten to the point where we got to end
this chris taping a new episode of chris
sims unbuttoned later today check that
out wherever you can find podcasts we'll
be back tomorrow with another edition of
pft live chris great stuff as always
we'll see you on thursday see you mike
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports